so Guillermo del Toro directed Hellboy
Hellboy has obtained the amphibian
creature in this movie looks like a bian
is directed by Guillermo del Toro and
played by the same actor who played Abe
Sapien in Hellboy which Guillermo del
Toro also directed but this is not an
Abe Sapien prequel spin-off or movie at
all cool the shape of water so the shape
of water is ultimately a sweet movie and
a violent movie directed by Guillermo
del Toro his lady works in this
government facility in the 1960s its
amidst the Cold War her and her friend
played by Octavia Spencer there the
janitors they just clean up the mess
around there but this government
facility led by Michael Shannon has
brought in a creature that's ultimately
like Creature from the Black Lagoon it's
easy to see this thing as a monster they
see the thing as a monster they see the
thing as a way to beat the Russians into
space but our star of the movie played
by Sally Hawkins develops a connection
with this creature and after that it
kind of becomes like et but with a
creature that's underwater what I like
about this movie is the performances are
oh great the movie looks fantastic
Guillermo del Toro always kills it on
that Michael Shannon is really menacing
as the main agent in this movie he's one
of those ones when he is on screen and
he is in a room he's the one you're
paying attention to no one upstages
Michael Shannon ever those movies
included Sally Hawkins in this movie
plays a bit of a loner bit of an
introvert and she also is a mute she
never talks in the movie and I take that
for granted a lot of the time it's easy
to think to yourself with the way people
convey the thoughts feelings and
emotions is through voice but it's
completely not like that that's one
element and angle of communication but
this Nala we have so what a character
like this comes along and completely
conveys any and all of her thoughts
feelings and emotions at any given time
it's really impressive doesn't say we're
in the movie yet she said so much this
is a lot of damn town but Richard
Jenkins was also great as her friend she
doesn't have a lot of friends so Richard
Jenkins is really her only friend bland
Octavia Spencer and the end fibbys
creature she made so Richard Jenkins is
always great at bringing heart into any
movies in he's one of the people you
wish was your neighbor my neighbors
actually watch this guy's I love you too
but if you guys move out I hope Richard
Jenkins character and this movie moves
in but the whole character dynamic in
this movie really was a great
representation of family with no blood
ties whatsoever and that was really for
like a better word sweet and that's
really what it is is how I can describe
this movie this movie is a very sweet
movie about connections I've seen a lot
of people and critics who review movies
saying this is one of the best movies of
the year it did not hit that realm for
me but I just found the movie very sweet
the connection she forms with this
creature from the Black Lagoon type
being is the most unexpected connection
since Naomi Watts and the ape from King
Kong but I'm always interested when a
director can show and convey that kind
of connection showing that human
connection really isn't limited to
humans the movies also kind of totally
unbalanced for me it's kind of a
guillermo del toro way of things here's
a sweet movie blood Wow hmm sometimes
it's bloody sometimes it's violent you
can argue well that's life but if it was
life itself I take a step back and I'm
like sometimes life that's as a little
tonally uneven that that sucked for you
to do that life I mean it for nothing
else at least it got the accurate ad
campaign that crimson peak that
guillermo del toro did before this
didn't get people winning the crimson
peak alright horror movie they walked
out like uh or gothic romance that was
weird this movie goes the more sweet
connection route and actually accurately
presents it not like they were like
here's Creature from the Black Lagoon
the horror movie guys in the end if
you're a guillermo del toro found you
like his imagination you like his
presentation and you sway to the side of
liking arthouse films is gonna be the
movie for you i appreciated this movie i
enjoyed this movie now let's say the
shape of water is a nice time no alcohol
acquired alright so the shape of water
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]